host I said okay our surveillance car if
I can have your attention and ask you to
be quiet please
what I'd like to do is I'd like to ask
you to refrain from shouting until we
finish the declaration yeah gonna go in
he be killed with eternity God fun
that's Canyon yeah Aykroyd sir he
commits Sonya you are welcome to take
photographs if you want
Revere Queen John's Swede O'Connell
yatta way threat Oh another four yard I
can I have without with fed over having
to login excise are Cabarrus a license
more and high rapid but Kevin's only
wear a plaid leisure at all with people
of invasive Paragon when I when Jones
acting returning officer at the election
held on Thursday a to do 2017 for the
initial own constituency give notice
that the total number of votes given to
each candidate was as follows
Davis Thomas David Wells Conservative
Party candidate against it applied gate
huatulco Murray dead meal three hunt at
we said Edward ten thousand three
hundred and eighty four
Jackson said I'm a Welsh Liberal
Democrats Democrats hide his blood oh
come rid petrol cans sized egg an out
479
[Applause]
Jones yeah downwind played Camry the
party of whales dag meal die guns are
three exercise
[Applause]
ten thousand two hundred and thirty
seven one
Albert Welsh Labour shower coming in
Comstock meal where hunt
fifteen thousand six hundred and forty
three Turner
James nicholas UK Independence Party you
Kip where hunt by the Edward 624 Roy
develop popular lately show all thought
with Bella gondola the number of ballot
papers rejected was as follows defeat
marks Widow Co once of official mark
zero played a show evil winocki you
negated voting for more candidates than
the water was entitled to eighteen ask
women never relegated ethnic caught at
preadly short right single mark by which
the water to be identified zero heavy
work yo nunca bankable villain or head
with unsecured with being an mad of
wholly void for uncertainty 22 come on
soon I will thought with total rejected
pet or day forty the she even by her
special cover this but Albert won with a
young a thought very Lawson adult are
covered a full life Venice more
therefore I gave public notice that
Albert Owen has been duly elected as the
Member of Parliament for the end is born
Tania moi thought
varam case with eco brawny vel Inigo
Leon we're now going to invite the
hundreds of individuals to say a few
words
well dill commode Yanni pouch Emma
bottom our guy heavy Piaf he dr. Gwen
Jones and whole team see with its
revenue the Foley Adama are heavy yet
Headley can I first of all thank you
Christina so late this morning and to
thank dr. Quinn and his team for
organizing this election not just today
but in the run-up to the election and
also the police of their presence and
their professionalism I also want to
thank the other candidate who should be
of the bobbin case see that it headed I
want to thank them all for their
courtesy that they've shown throughout
this campaign it was a snap election but
it feels like a long campaign and I also
want to thank my family my excellent
agent and the team that have been with
me for these few weeks across the island
we've taken the message to the people of
in this mall and I'm pleased with the
outcome but the supporters have been
excellent and I want you to give them
and give themselves a big hand
each each election is different and
what's been different about this one I
think has been the involvement of the
young people on this moon
many thousands of extra young people
registered took part and they were
active in my campaign and they have
inspired me for the future and I pay
tribute to them for their help their
ideas and I hope that I will they put
their trust in me that I will reward
them but most of all I want to thank the
people of earnest multi-shot the
opposite one somebody please show me Ark
Troy US and another Anatolia oma we
where in the beginning as the Labour
Party our backs to the wall and we won
against the odds even the bookies odds
and I know some of the press we're
betting on 16 to 1 for me not winning
the seats not just winning it but not
winning this seat as well but seriously
the people of earnest small do not
always follow trends we are a unique
constituency we are unique in many many
ways not just as an island but there's a
people and this campaign was marred by
the tragic events in both Manchester and
London but at the end of the day
democracy will always win democracy has
150 he got found mr. finish I was asked
by a young man today what would I do
win or lose this election and I said
well I have six weeks of weeds growing
in the garden that I need to tender
that'll be my first job and but I do
want to finish because I always mention
absent friends and I would like to
dedicate this election to my good friend
we lost recently rotary Morgan Roger
Morgan was a true giant of Welsh
politics he was a friend he was a
comrade
he was a great Welshman or than come
Rocco young Italian ting law v both of
them Emma
I only have you and I just wanted to say
when I first won this seat in 2001 the
first politician to phone me up was
Rhodri Morgan and he said one word been
big a dick and I say to